okay we are live what up guys welcome to
the just early things youtube channel
today i have a special guest on the
channel
sam
you're right
thanks for having me
it always confuses me guys when they say
you are right here
it's like how are you right
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
in the u.s it's um
it's like you you'd ask that to someone
if they're not if they don't look good
yeah it's the same here but it's just
casual
yeah yeah
sometimes it like throws me off a little
bit
uh before i start guys do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification
bell that we are going to be notified of
my daily videos while you're at it if
you want to get my attention during the
stream send a donation and i i'll read
it aloud to the panel
also all donations are going to be
for the second set of sound boards and
the second set of mics so that way i can
host eight people here instead of four
so yes and donations
so the topic today is
is the whole phase necessary after
heartbreak and what
inspired this topic everybody's fine
is that sam over here just got out of an
eight-year relationship
yep
so when did that end
it's fresh in 2022 sort of through
january it all ended
what do you mean like through jet like
was
it was like
we'd sit down we'd have a chat
i didn't see things working or going
forwards
but then we try but the connection
sparks just wasn't there anymore and
things had happened in the past that
just didn't make me comfortable being
there anymore
was it a distance thing like were you no
no we live together oh okay we still
live together wait you should live with
her i didn't tell you that yes no
yeah so
london london living prices and all that
oh
so
god i was not expecting that how does
that work
it's a bit awkward
is it is it a two bedroom one bed i'm on
the sofa for the next few months until
the tenancy
runs out do you guys like date other
people
well it's still fresh but
i don't know about her but i'm
out there again yeah and
oh my gosh i'm like i'm just imagining
like yeah yeah okay
i i did not realize that okay so when
did you guys meet you met when she was
or you were you're 20. i'm 24 now yeah
we must have met
when we were 15 maybe okay
yeah and it took a couple of years
and then we got together
and now it's
yeah done
and you said you broke it off right yeah
i broke it off um can i ask why
um
maybe not on here no
that's okay um because it's kind of
uncommon because i was saying before
usually girls initiate breakups
um
but then why do they do that why why
does d why do girls end a relationship
um well
you're not in the red pill are you
the red pill yes you guys mean by that
like do you know who rolo tomasi is
never do you know have you heard of
hypergamy no yeah guys this is very like
this is a weird sector of youtube i'm
gonna warn you okay
so hypergamy means basically like if a
woman settles down with a guy
she has to see him as like the best that
she can do
so women often leave because they get
attention from other men and they think
they can do better
so
like oftentimes a girl is like moving on
to the next best thing
okay i'd say um it's hard to find the
next best thing from me
well it wasn't the case in that because
it was a relationship
yeah and maybe that was a little bit
from me instead yeah yeah yeah
i've also seen like i feel like if guys
date a girl super young it's like kind
of hard because they don't get to have
like their wild you know
yeah obviously like
together from 16 to 24 so yeah
i've never been wild wild yeah yeah
there's been thoughts
but
nothing crazy on a night out
yeah
so how does living with her work
like do you guys talk still
is it do you agree with each other like
the start has always been like you know
how are things going to work out like if
we're both at home in the evening are we
going to have dinner together and stuff
yeah
like our schedules at the moment just
work so it's just only really one of us
at the house at a time
apart from at night
it's been manageable so far yeah and how
have you been doing like i can't ima i
cannot imagine that would wreck me i
would be done
after an eight-year relationship i would
be done
i think where is me that ended it i've
taken it much better
i
don't want to sound like a douche but
it feels like a weight off the shoulders
and somewhat moving on to happier things
yeah
okay so you're doing okay yeah i'm good
you're good do you so what do you think
of the title tonight
there's a few opinions on it
um
but
is it necessary
i'd say it's a personal thing it's a
personal thing yeah
do you think it's different between the
sexes
100 okay so what do you think for guys
and for girls in general it doesn't have
to be specific
i'd say from a guy's perspective
coming out the relationship
yes i downloaded tinder straight away
but then
where do you bring them yeah
but like you know it's not getting to
every friday night and i'm not out in
shoreditch like yeah let's try get this
girl yeah
obviously the end of the relationship
the last few months there's been no
sexual relationship
but
what not so much but
oh no wonder you got no like
obviously there's a need but i wouldn't
say it's
something i'm going out there to look
for and fulfill
i'm open-minded now and just looking
for what do i want in life
i feel like the whole face is bad for
girls
i think it kind of like mentally
it doesn't like do well i think girls
have like more consequences for a whole
face than a guy
there can be more consequences yeah like
i feel like girls
aren't really like meant to do that
but is anyone meant to do it
biologically yeah men are
because you have to think like back in
the day like men are more programmed to
like spread their seed where women are
programmed to find the best quality mate
that they can
yeah in general in general yeah
that rubs you the wrong way i can see it
in your eyes
no it is that is history that is
evolution and stuff so yeah
but i'd say also today we live
in a very sexualized society
where
particularly from like the age of 16 to
21
it seems everyone just wants to shag
no i um
well it's different because
in the old days like people would
get married so young and find their
partner so young
but nowadays the average age in the uk
of first marriage what do you think it
is
nowadays yeah
probably
late 20s
it's 31 for women 31 for women 20. like
32 for men
yeah in the u.s it's like 28 for women
29 for men okay
but
marriage is dying out as well i'd say
yeah i'm not particularly bothered about
getting married
but obviously i do want to have a long
lasting relationship
there's someone i love
but at the end of the day marriage just
a piece of paper
what is marriage what is mere that
well we actually we talk a lot about
marriage on the channel because it
doesn't particularly benefit men and i
think men are kind of walking away from
marriage
because it's like there's about 50 50.
yeah like i don't think that's fair to
guys actually like
um like if i was to marry someone and
get divorced like i could file for what
is it called
when even if we didn't have a kid like i
could file for like they'd still have to
pay me just for being married yeah wow
i'm like that's that's crazy and even
with kids like that's the number one
reason nba players go broke
you get the wrong girl pregnant
wow
you gotta be careful with you yeah
then
when you're famous
you can afford it
oh no that's why they go not if they're
taking 50 of your income
i'd happily be on
six seven figures and lose 50 of it
yeah but no a lot of people that get
rich quick don't really have the money
skills to like sustain it you know what
i mean like they just spend it all yeah
buy a house by cars yeah
true try to live a lavish lifestyle
so um how long were you thinking about
the breaking up with her before you did
was she like blindsided or did she kinda
you know see it coming
i think she was a little bit blindsided
but i'd say
the last couple of years were a struggle
but really where i just
felt
it had to end
probably
end of december started january okay
yeah now i need to get out of this and
did she see it coming
i don't think so no no was she really
sad
yeah she was yeah
she still
struggles with it yeah
she went away for a week
and she did call me while she was away
i was like
how are things going to work living in
the flat together still
what if you start getting feelings for
me again stuff like that i was like
i just don't see having it at all like
you don't need to worry about that
okay i probably didn't feel that
savagely
don't worry i'm good
you have no feelings at all after eight
years
obviously i still
like like
don't feel bad for her i'm a decent
human i'm not yeah yeah
but
in terms of a relationship and spark
there's just nothing there no more yeah
i i don't see any ever coming back
because
what has happened
to that
i asked you before the stream
you don't want me to ask
and i was told no true right yeah you
were except that yeah except that
okay so what have you
so it was kind of like emotionally you
were kind of like done before the
relationship ended
yeah which is why i've probably found it
easier yeah
to move on that's how it was um because
i just got out of a relationship in like
december and i think i was thinking
about breaking up with him for like two
months because he broke up with him what
you broke up with him no i did yeah i
did but i was still really sad because i
didn't really like
want to
but it's like
i i kind of had to to be honest so
was that long distance is he in the
states yeah i use it in the states so i
guess i think it was
the second i came here it was kind of
like
doomed we tried but you know yeah
because we were sort of
semi-long-distance-ish at the start of
the relationship yeah
two three-hour car journey which is
obviously not quite the states from
london but
and things worked fine then
but
[ __ ] happened
[Music]
gosh it sounds
is it cheating no no no
she's never cheated on me yeah
like that's what it sounds like
but [ __ ] happened okay two three hour
how long did you guys do distance for
uh
probably
[Music]
a year two years
okay yeah it wasn't too long i hated
distance it was not
and then we've lived together for
maybe five years
something like that
oh wow five years yeah so you guys moved
in together when you were
probably
19 or 20.
would you like recommend that like would
you do that again or would you get
married before you lived with someone
else
um
no i wouldn't you wouldn't get you
wouldn't do it again i wouldn't get
married first okay you need to live with
someone before you can marry them oh i
disagree
i like i don't want to live with anyone
until i marry get married
but then
[Music]
living with someone you don't know what
their habits are like having someone
over for a weekend or a week is
completely different to living with them
for five years a hundred years
for life i just feel like okay this is
my opinion okay and i think it's the
right one you're entitled to it
so i feel like what else are you gonna
learn about someone like i think most of
my friends i can tell if they're messy
or clean or whatever and i feel like
people
avoid marriage because they're afraid of
like finding something out there being
like some dark skeleton or things
changing or whatever
but
i don't know i'd rather just like
try it give it my best shot then like
you know spend my life like afraid that
something's gonna come out or we won't
live together like you can figure that
stuff out
and i guess it comes back to is
what is marriage what's the difference
of you living with someone
before and after marriage well i think
marriage is more like conducive to
families
like i would i wouldn't want to have a
kid outside of like i feel like marriage
like i was always happy my parents were
married i think that was good for me as
a kid
yeah yeah yeah we're all my family
apart from yeah there's two
relationships now that i've broken down
and been divorced now in my family but
everyone else is married and fine with
their families but
i don't know me and my ex we never saw
marriage as a thing yeah
we saw it as
okay do the paperwork for all the legal
matters and stuff like that
like
obviously i know a woman wants her big
day and all that stuff yeah for me
i'm an introvert i don't want all that
attention
like a courthouse you know he doesn't
have a big like
but
yeah but if i find the right person and
yeah she wants to have the big day i'll
do that for her yeah
it seems like britain isn't as like i've
heard that a lot in britain
okay the
like what's the difference between
living with someone and getting married
like that that seems to be very common
here
have you seen love is blind
on netflix i saw see the first season i
haven't seen a second yeah i vaguely
remember the first season
but that's very
oh my god i would do that that sounds
like so much fun
you would do it oh yeah
someone else who i spoke about it to
yesterday and she was like she has no
understanding of how people can do that
like how can you
decide to marry someone just through
obviously they talk to each other
probably a lot more than we see on the
show but still only through maybe 10 15
20 hours of talking from
to them through a wall
how can they decide that
you want to marry that person
i don't know i don't think dating longer
decreases the risk of divorce i actually
have
i don't want to quote these because i'm
afraid like it's been a while since i've
looked at them but i went to catholic
school and so they would always have
like chastity speakers come in
and um one of the
they would always quote a statistic that
said that people that didn't live
together before they were married tend
to be married longer
you know yeah i'll go you mean yeah and
like i just feel like
at some point like there's going to be
some risk
like no matter how long you date a
person there's always going to be risk
you know
no i'm not going to lie reality tv maybe
not
maybe that that probably isn't the best
way to do it
plus when are those statistics from
they're probably from
10 15 years ago
yeah yeah yeah i agree that's why
it was 50 years ago it's even a
different work to what it was 10 years
ago now
yeah you don't change the world actually
the development of birth control
because before that like people had to
get married so much younger like how
many grandparents got married because
the grandma was like knocked up
yeah i guess so but then there's been a
lot in the news
if you had seen it but in the uk
of
people in like the 60s when they did get
pregnant out of wedding out of marriage
they had to give up their child
really i've never heard of that there's
been a lot of
like
women who are now like 40 and they're
just meeting their actual biological
mother really and it was all like a
government thing i haven't ever heard of
that
it's in the uk yeah yeah and now there's
some sort of investigation into it and
apology going to all those 60 year old
ladies who had to give up their child
it's a bit late for that but
yeah yeah oh my god that is insane
i you know i had my mom gave up a kid
for adoption actually
really yeah i met him when i was 22. i
found out he existed is he older
yeah yeah my dad knocked up my mom when
she was 17
and i got married five years later but
yeah when they were 22 they told me i
had a brother named greg
and i was like what kind of name is greg
no offense greg if you're watching this
like respectfully
but yeah i guess they were telling the
truth and they gave
up him for adoption and he's like fine
and stuff he grew up to be like a
software sales software engineer
but it was crazy the similarities are
actually like nuts really yeah
he like walks like us
did your grandparents know about that
yeah they did okay they wanted to keep
it they want to keep it yeah they wanted
my mom to keep him wow okay they were
like very against it my mom
but yeah my mom
just didn't feel like she was ready she
was too young
sensible choice then yeah i know
but
interesting
i feel like i keep getting off topic i
do that a lot i'm not already going
through this
well because i thought you'd have like a
strong opinion one way or the other with
the whole face
do you think anything is just sorry
because of the whole
way society is sexualized in every way
now that
it seems girl guys have just got like
lad banner go out there pull girls
and then
girls watching all this reality tv are
like oh yeah i gotta find a guy and
sleep with him stuff like that i feel
when you do get out of relationship
like mine where there's not been that
sexual relationship for the last
couple of months
maybe it's something that you're looking
for and you're just like yeah get me
anything yeah yeah
but
i wouldn't say it's necessary yeah
it's a need of some people yeah
do you think that's good for society or
bad for society that it's so sexualized
now because some some people have talked
to think it's like a good thing
and others think it's the worst thing
ever
um
i'd say i'm neutral about it like
at the end of the day what has made
is marketing that's made everything
sexual and
that makes money and boosts the comedy
and makes people rich
then it's good
would you oh actually i got a question
would you date a girl with an only fans
but she's making enough money to like
depends on the content really how
no it's it's it's sexual content but
but
she's making millions
i'd get in on it
you'd get in on it yeah
be the special guest in the content
really
so you would you would would you marry a
girl
that didn't have any fans yeah mother of
your kids
it would definitely have to be a
conversation
i'd have to be a converse so maybe you'd
consider it
it would be a conversation
i think that is not i don't know what
way it would go
hold on i'm gonna check the chat really
quick
also if you send a 50 super chat
i don't drink but i'll take a shot
right
um okay let me read see if anyone's put
questions in the in the chat
um
[Music]
you need
what do you think of this comment you
need to hook up with 60 girls as a man
to be able to understand them and have
standards
i'd say from an eight-year relationship
i've certainly got the understanding of
females
i want to ask you
questions what do you mean by that
like what do you understand about
females recently
just how they deal with life
and like
every female is different and like
i think you really do have to go for a
big talking phase to get to know someone
first
to know if you're compatible
and like what your values are
and if you if so if it's actually
something that can work in the future
because
opposites don't always attract
and within a relationship it's probably
never really going to attract
so what does that have to do with like
females
what about them
no you said you understand like female
nature now or like you understand more
about females like what have you learned
it's okay we can skip it if you don't
yeah i mean um
what do you care about body count
what in terms of lab band or
looking for a partner no like a girl
you're trying to date says i wouldn't
date a girl unless she if like she had
to have slept
any woman with a body count under 10
seems like potential girlfriend material
to me only two
probably would be insanely to hard to
find in the west
um no i wouldn't say body count matters
like
it's all about
the future and values going forward
if she's still going to be
sleeping around going forward then
nine interested but
if she's slept with 20 guys before
that she's now
matured and sees the future and how she
wants to live
that doesn't matter
guys what do we call this
unique
blue pill
i'm a mixer of all pills no no you're
blue pill
um
just uh
let's see
i became
i'm just gonna go through the comments
really quick and i'll ask you more
questions
is the whole face necessary no eating is
necessary so is drinking and working a
whole phase is an easy way to mitigate
the consequences of bad decision making
in my opinion of course
um
so if she's been with 60
okay this is a cool
and she's been with 60 guys and a gang
bang does it matter
oh yeah you find out you're dating a
girl she's great okay
she's she's good in bed has all the
values you're looking for okay perfect
yep then you find out
um
she let five guys hit it in one night
in college
do you care
i don't think so everyone's got history
it's blue pale thinking
you know there's things in my history
that i wouldn't say i regret because
there's nothing regretting anything
you've done you just learn from it do
you feel like it's different for men and
women sleeping around
when how it feels or the opinion of it
no yeah like the opinion of it
well yeah guys sleeping around just
seemed like he's a lad top giza yeah
whereas a woman she's seen as
her yeah
yeah it's kind of a double standard yeah
it's the biggest double standard there
is yeah like so that's why when i was
kind of getting at earlier like even if
you had stuff because
matt like when women sleep with men it's
a sign of pre-selection so like back in
the day
we had to pick a mate we would want a
guy that protected other women
so like that's why it's like a double
standard because there's biological
reasoning where men don't like it
because
they needed to ensure paternity and a
girl that was sleeping around like you
don't know if that's the paternity of
your kid
so there's like biological reasons
behind double standards okay
yeah i'll get that yeah
yeah so yeah it's how it seemed today
really yeah
i i would tell my brother to avoid a
girl that sleeps around a lot to be
honest that's what i tell him
but then would you ever see yourself as
someone who sleeps around a lot i don't
know
no i don't
what's your opinion on girls who do
any of your teammates
no i mean it's all it all depends right
like there's individual differences
but
i think girls that sleep around a lot
have a harder time like being faithful
at times if i'm being honest
is there a reason a girl sleeps around a
lot
um
attention validation
and she just needs to find the right guy
sometimes yeah you're right sometimes
but i talk about general advice not
specifics you know like i can always
think of exceptions to the role
[Music]
okay
but
what else do i want to ask you is the
whole phase necessary you don't want to
talk about why you guys broke up
no that is deep that is deep
psychology you could do your master's
dissertation on that
but it wasn't cheating no no no no but
it wasn't cheating huh
but
i mean if you're not sleeping together
for months like i feel like if a guy
isn't getting it from you like he's
either going to break up with you or go
somewhere else
it's not the reason no but because of
the other things going on
yeah i lost the sexual attraction
oh really but then i didn't feel the
need to go out and get it elsewhere yeah
because i still wanted to stay loyal and
try work things
and get through it but
it just went on and on and on and
couldn't get through it
and
very vague
sorry i'm nosy that's fine
so
was it you lost the track did she like
gain weight or something
no no i'm not that shallow
wasn't like gaining weight it wasn't
was it like was it oh was it was it
jealous behavior
jenna's behavior yeah
nah should trust me this answer isn't
going to come out online
okay okay
have you ever dealt with jealousy like
are you a jealous guy
i'd say i can't be a jedis guy yeah i'm
kind of jealous have you ever have you
ever gone through a girl's phone no no i
won't go through her phone no
she's gone through mine yeah i think
every girl has at some point
but maybe there was reason to go through
mine
yeah
in the first couple of years like i did
still have tinder and stuff like that
are you a tinder yeah yeah
but that's like how do you say no one
cheated
if you had tinder
you just never met with anyone else
so i was like then why have it
i don't know i was 17 and stupid oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay i got you
interesting
the whole phase necessary
what have you done to like get over your
past relationship did you
um
like what's helped you get through it
because i can't even imagine eight years
even even if you weren't emotionally
involved that's still a lot
um
i think i've just
obviously where it was my decision there
wasn't particularly too much heartbreak
on my side which i'm not cold-hearted
and i'm not just over like that yeah
eight years a long time
but
i think just trying to
get out there be myself again and be
happy
what advice would you have for someone
that's going through a breakup
[Music]
if you don't feel like you can be
yourself in that relationship
however hard it is
saying no to that person you don't want
to be together you've got to do it for
your own
like well-being
because
again it's horrible to say but i'm
happier now yeah
no disrespect to her but i'm happier now
no me too yeah me too like i understand
it's
hard to say like no you don't want to be
mean that
it's freedom and a bit of like weight
off your shoulders like i said earlier
such a weight off your shoulders exactly
i don't know
i was in a very like
like very like he was jealous kind of
controlling you know that type of thing
and like just like i felt like i was a
like a kid getting like
how i put it like let like like your
parents like getting out of my parents
house because
i
was so tired of like having to like
answer to someone all the time you know
what i mean like
yeah that's
how i felt that i just couldn't be
myself anymore
if we were still in the relationship i
wouldn't be here tonight yeah or come on
any of the other shows because i just
feel
i have to be there with her yeah
yeah because now i'm just like
a free man did you come to that party i
threw when i first got here nope oh no
it's funny because when did you get here
though because i joined volleyball late
november
well i got here october 15th
okay or 20th like something like that
and then
i threw that party for my birthday it
was like the fourth
no you weren't there
i didn't know anyone though so it was
kind of like oh my god there was so much
going on yeah it was also like when i
started uni
was i was still with her so very much
i'd be on campus
do my lectures do my volleyball go home
to her
whereas now i'm more just out there
myself
being around other people do you guys
have intertwined friend groups because i
didn't with my ex-boyfriend and that
made it a lot easier but i can't you
guys dated for eight years so is it hard
with the mutual friends
it's 50 50 like when she was at uni all
the friends she made
i became friends with
and like
i know she has spoken to them about the
breakup
i'm surprised they haven't messaged me
about it at all
i would like to know what she said to
them and her side of it
obviously i've said to my friends and my
family my side of it yeah but
there's always two stories two sides of
things it's always going to be yeah
perceived differently yeah
but um
no
we both were also both in volleyball in
england there's a lot of people we both
know oh she plays volleyball yeah yeah
where does she play uh she doesn't
actually play at the moment she only
coaches at the moment
oh wow um
at the guys game yesterday in kingston
as a fella who came across to me he said
hi we were good friends together in
southampton
and our house feelings how's things how
she and i was like
we've broken up
it's like oh damn yeah we went we went
out a lot together
all of us well so it's really awkward
when people ask you and you're like
yeah it is awkward like
when i first especially
an eight-year relationship it wasn't
something i wanted to talk to my family
about like on the phone or texting them
so i didn't wait till i went down there
again to talk to them about it
they picked me up from the coach station
or in the car they're like oh how's she
like
yeah she's okay it was like then we sat
down for lunch or breakfast and it's
like actually we have broken up this
happened
yeah
it's
it's tough just like talking through
with everyone yeah and i went out with
my friends that night
i'm up with a mate told him about it we
picked someone up in the car told him
about it got to where we're going tell
him tell everyone else about it it's
like guys can we just talk about this
once and once only and everyone at once
not everyone individually as we see them
i feel like girls we talk more
so i what i've noticed like i feel like
girls when we go through a breakup like
we'll tell our whole friend group we're
gonna talk [ __ ] obviously like
and
she doesn't no that's part of the issue
she just doesn't talk enough
oh okay that's really good she's not
talking [ __ ] around town yesterday
see ways she can manipulate that i've
done it wrong but
if she does she does at the end of the
day i know why i've done what i've done
yeah
and
if anyone wants to question me on it
come question me on it yeah i'll tell
you straight how it was from my side
yeah yeah
but not on the line
okay wait i'm gonna look for the chat um
someone says
let's see
pearl throwing parties and we weren't
invited on
subscribing
guys guys i threw one party when i got
here
i don't even drink and all these people
showed up i didn't even know it was like
it wasn't
oh my gosh
and then
i
[Music]
one i'm not gonna read that one
my advice is to go home and cry that
[ __ ] out breakups hurt you gotta work
through it hitting the gym worked for me
as well that's what
midas the stallion says wow
have you are you after breakup do you go
to the gym are you like uh
i mean don't tell william but i haven't
been to the gym all year
just yeah i do want to get back in the
gym
before i moved to london i was in the
gym
and i'm healthy i'm out but yeah i moved
to london like life's busy yeah but i do
want to get back in there
i enjoy training
i'll get rid of the dad bod
um i think you need different friend
groups you need a break from each other
at first do you think that's true
yeah we definitely like yeah it's so
awkward in the house at the moment there
there needs to be a break
yeah
and then
[Music]
i don't know how did you come back
together after a break
how do you
um oh my god i can't even imagine living
with someone i'm still dating like i'm
trying to wrap my head around that
yeah
that's
i don't even know what if you like dated
someone new like what
like because if a guy told me he still
lived with his ex i would be like oh god
have you told girls that yeah yeah do
they care
uh no they understand
oh okay is that kind of in here
i think it's just maturity
that the girls i've been talking to yeah
there is one who i've spoken to she's
been in a similar situation where she's
been in a long-term relationship
and she's had issues they've broken up
and like you know it's not a clean snap
like that when you've been in a
long-term relationship there is stuff
you share
yeah
and then
yeah people understand yeah if you're
just truthful and honest people
understand
oh my gosh i can't even
that was i was like do you see my face
when you told me that yeah
like oh gosh
um
let me see if there's anything else in
the chat
that it's a grieving process
sleeping around is bad for society and
it has resulted in the decline of
marriage
um
increasing bastard kit oh my gosh never
mind
do you no sex until marriage will
alleviate a lot of confusion what do you
think about that
i don't get how people can't have sex
before marriage
i used to want to when i was younger
yeah
i like wanted to
i wish i did actually
but then what was the sexist crap
how would i know if i'd never had sex
with anyone else
like you have nothing to compare it to
you know
yeah but just because you've got nothing
to compare it to doesn't mean it
still wouldn't
feel right yeah
and like it's a very intimate process
yeah what if you go through
five six years together you get married
you live together and it just doesn't
feel right having sex like something
just isn't there
then what
something just doesn't there
yeah i feel like i would just like deal
with it and focus on other things
she's thinking about work
no
okay i just for me i don't think that's
like the most important thing in a
relationship like
values and like
you know
that that sort of thing i think is more
important than like sex because i feel
like sex can be learned like you can
figure that out
then how is it
i don't like you learn with each other
right like
yeah i guess yeah
um
let's see
but then are you comfortable to like
learn together and have those
conversations if you're each other's
only sexual partner
yeah i mean i would think so like
i feel like you can
oh my gosh i don't want to like say too
much
but i feel like you can like
tell someone what you like and what you
don't like you know
if it's your first sexual experience how
do you know what you like
i don't know
i feel like
i feel like you know on some level
no i'd say
it took me a while to find out what i do
and don't like
oh god
um
he is being careful with the how he
speaks because he's talking to a woman
he doesn't want to ruffle your feathers
i have no filter i'm just being careful
out of
respect for my ex and there's a lot yeah
that doesn't need to be out there yeah
yeah
um
have you watched the tinder swunder
no
but i am planning on watching it with
someone
yeah
do you know what happened
i've seen it around on social media sort
of yeah has that been your experience on
tinder
i don't think i've seen enough to know
what you mean by that oh no he like um
got
basically like free stuff you got girls
to take out hundreds of thousands of
dollars in loans
yeah i've never experienced that i'm not
giving anyone money without knowing them
no they give him the girls gave him
money i'm not going out looking for
money
and i'm a student and poor but you know
oh my gosh
well
i appreciate you coming on is there
anything else you want to talk about on
the podcast on the podcast
yeah
um
you i watched
the last one earlier today okay i'm
trying to think what tickled me
what tickled you yeah i grubbed you the
wrong way
was it me did i say something what did i
say
i'm opinionated so i wouldn't be shocked
what did you go through
it was about
toxicity wasn't it oh that one yeah okay
toxic are we attracted to toxic
relationships
like
i wouldn't say men
look for a toxic relationship
but i'd
say most toxic women are the typical
mean girls
type of women which is what a man wants
so that's what they end up with
wait so you think men are attracted to
toxic women
yeah okay
elaborate
they're not attracted to the toxicity
okay
this seems a typical toxic woman is
a pretty girl gets her nails done la la
la okay yeah i'd agree obviously
that's what a guy wants they want a
pretty girl who looks after herself yeah
so they just end up with that toxic girl
it's not necessarily they're not looking
for the top so you think it's like
because they're hot basically the hot
girls are the toxic ones yeah okay yeah
i could see that for sure
because i feel like there's pretty
privilege you know
so the more attractive you are like the
more people kind of give you the benefit
of the doubt yeah and they contention
yeah and so with that it's like
like girls always say the best guys are
the former fat ones
because they became funny to get girls
i mean
i was fat and i wouldn't say i'm funny
[Music]
you're a little funny on the you had a
funny answer when i interviewed you the
other day
that that i've seen that back that
answer doesn't even make sense to me now
i thought it was the best one actually
because i so i asked him
what's the difference between a woman
showing
that she's what did i say it was like
what's the difference between a woman
um playing hard to get and actually
being interested
i said something about them in bed no
you said like it's how quick they get
into bed yeah something like that yeah
which is kind of like kind of true
she puts her money where her mouth is
she's actually interested
right
yes
but what i've learned through talking to
people recently is no no
no okay elaborate
there are some girls who
want to get to know you they're not
being hard to get but it's just
their way of wanting to get into a real
relationship that they aren't just going
to jump straight into bed yeah no that's
true
because
well and i think women are more
risk-averse
well yeah there's a lot of risks yeah
women having sex yeah more than like a
guy yeah yeah
but no that was kind of funny
i was like i hope he's not mad i posted
that clip
just fine i remember waking up in the
middle of the night and seeing it
oh god it's up there
no it's fine it's in a youtube video i
made
so
um you think so back to the toxic
relationships
do you
think
like men are addicted to the toxicity or
do you think men tend to leave because
i think women
get kind of addicted to it
like i think we
finding toxic men yeah oh for sure like
you hear the girls on the show
yeah yeah one of them had a few toxic
relationships yeah no um and like
something becomes addicting about it but
then
on the show
i mean she's a lovely girl but you had
gabby and she said she's been the cause
of the toxic relationship and she's been
the toxic one oh yeah yeah it's a pretty
girl with a nice body and stuff like
that so
that's what guys go for not because she
is toxic but because she's got that
figure and attraction that guys want
well i think that in like any toxic
relationship like you have to admit like
it takes two to tango
right so both people in a toxic
relationship are toxic
to some extent yeah
i think you either like especially if
you allow it like i've definitely
allowed [ __ ] that like
wasn't okay but i like i'm not gonna sit
here and cry me a river when i stayed
you know what i mean
okay would you class this as toxic okay
so
i met my ex in
summer
20
let's say fifth no no no earlier than
that 13 something like that
we got together we got to know each
other blah blah blah
she wasn't interested in me
i then got of another girl
i then met up with my ex again
and we tried it again
and i left this other girl immediately
for her
oh okay is that toxic
or is that i don't know
i i broke that other girl's heart
um i wouldn't say it's toxic i would say
like toxic to me is
if you did you use that girl to get make
the other girl jealous i'd say that
would be toxic
but i wouldn't say that i wouldn't say
that was my intentions but that's what
happened yeah well
i would say um it's more like the toxic
no i think she was just your second
choice it sucks but
yeah like most people have happened to
at some point you can't be everyone's
first choice sometimes you get
bamboozled
yeah like
so i would just say she took an owl
okay
but i wouldn't say i would say toxic is
like lying like
um
i would say lying is mostly toxic like
not taught like
i don't want to like give too much
[Music]
i don't know mostly like lying i would
say is toxic behavior or
you know what's it called when like
gaslighting or like when they switch it
and like put it on you when they're like
guilty about something super jealous
like crazy stuff
like call it i
yeah that's what i think of let's see i
don't i don't think thank you for the
five dollar super chat black ops
i appreciate you it's going towards the
sound board okay
i don't think men are not attracted to
toxic women but are attracted to
attractive women no man seeks out toxic
women sam is the goat
that was the goat
tree why why why am i go
because you were they like them
they like the men that can like juggle
the women you know what i mean like
because a lot of my audience is men it's
like 80 men 20 women something like that
so
they my audience likes guys that can
like get girls
like i think they admire it so you're go
because you had the two
because
some guys can't get one
there's two or three on the go now as
well
there's two or three on the go now
yeah
so you got three girls you're talking to
now
only one at the moment now there's been
others oh okay i mean since the end of
january there's been three but now
there's only one okay do you like her
yeah
like like her like her or like like her
yeah i mean we've seen each other a
couple of times okay it's gone well yeah
tinder no no no
uni you already know her no no do i know
her no she was
she work at sports dog man
i'm nosy
you might have seen her i don't think he
would have seen her around her when i've
seen her that's okay i don't really know
people so
no one would know her from
okay do you want to get in another
relationship or is it like
are you like the streets i love the
streets i'm never going back no so
i'd say
i've taken a lot of time the last few
weeks to like
just think what do i want from a
relationship what can i offer to a
relationship
and now it's just
taking the time to find the right person
for that
um
however soon that happens
doesn't particularly bother me
are you just unhappy to take the time to
get to know someone yeah so you're not
really like jumping into anything but
you're open to it
i'm open to being exclusive but not like
directly straight into a relationship
okay but like
i don't know
it's okay you can say i don't know
that's an answer
what are you doing
what are you oh my gosh i have another
question how long do you think it's too
long to be in the talking stage
i wouldn't say that too long like
you see
you know series like friends they
eventually all get together after being
years of friends
but years yeah
but uh when does a friendship become a
relationship or when does getting to
know someone become a relationship
that's the hardest when do you decide to
move into like
okay let's try be a couple
let's try and make this work as an us
i don't know it's like if you're i see
couples where like they're basically in
a relationship they're over like at each
other's houses like three times a week
so it's like at that point you might as
well date
if you're not sleeping with other people
and then is the guy just in the friend
zone
i would think the girl was in the friend
zone
because girl if she's sleeping with him
here he's getting sex
yeah but no sex involved oh no sex
involved no
okay i was thinking when i hear talking
like i think of like like you're
sleeping together
not all the time okay that's what i i'm
automatically assumed so when i say so
how long is too long to be in the
talking stage if you are sleeping
together if you are sleeping together
yeah
if you're sleeping together there's no
limit on that i don't think you don't
think so but i feel like if you've been
talking to someone
with
no sexual relationship for
a year
okay maybe six months
how do you then i would tell a guy to
let it go after like two months really
yeah
and this in 2022 yeah
unless she's like the rush
oh is the rush i'm i'm with you i'm just
saying like as general advice like
like there
are guys like
like
i think kind of wait like girls kind of
see his backup plans
and like they don't when they really
like they're just there like because
they they want the other guy but they'll
deal with that guy
true and they're sleeping with the other
guy
and they'll they'll still be like
talking to you because
yeah i'm a girl i get to know like the
behind the scenes if you're close enough
you'll know something's going on
and you'll know you're the second guy
i know you got you girls are snakey
aren't
you i don't know
unless you're sleeping there i think you
wouldn't if like but if she's not
sleeping there
how would you know unless she just said
okay i'm going to bed
text the other guy he comes over
but what's the issue with that
if things don't work with that other guy
and you two still have a good
relationship
obviously no one wants to be a second
choice no one does want to be a second
chance i was like you wouldn't have a
problem with that
but would you know
no you probably wouldn't but that's why
i said like in general i would tell a
guy to let it go after like two months
if she doesn't sleep with you three
if like she isn't you know i'm saying in
general you know there's some girls that
like
are slower with that stuff
yeah definitely yeah right
especially now i feel like i'm getting
old
you're only 24
okay i just turned 25 in november
but like
i'm not in an age where i just want to
be sleeping round
my brother's engaged now yeah he's a
fair bit older than me
my sister i mean i don't know what she's
doing
she's single and living life she's happy
she's older than me
but
i want to have
a family you know a few kids stuff like
that so
whatever it takes to get to that
i want to try to get there so i'm not
going to sleep around to try and find
that yeah i want to find someone who has
the same values as me
and is driven towards that goal
i don't know where this started from so
i don't know where i'm heading because i
was saying i would let it go after two
months if
not not i wouldn't let it go i wouldn't
let him to let it go because like i
think people should sleep around like if
anything i don't think that like i'm the
opposite
but what i'm saying is like i think
she's probably not into you
yeah but maybe she's in the same boat as
me and that she is still waiting to see
if this is the right guy and ultimately
is about
how the relationship works yeah before
things get sexual yeah well i mean again
this is in general they're specifically
like you know exceptions right there's
exceptions to every rule yeah but if the
girl's like
not a virgin like she's probably
sleeping with someone in my opinion
most of the time
most of the time in general
[Music]
i wouldn't say that's true
what do you guys think blue pill
blue pill blue pill
okay um
super chat another five dollar super
chat
i was told team building exercise is how
men bond you should do an escape room
with this girl
we can't do an escape room with two
people
what do you have any any friends yeah
okay wow
yeah like we
there's stuff we planned and stuff like
that yeah they think you look like wheat
waffles do you want to see who that is
yeah i want to see who that is
i'll show you guys he's a content
creator
where is he
i said i hope that's not him i don't
look like that no no
where he responds to his face
can i turn off the sound because the
chat will be able to hear it
oh this guy
i will never go clean shaven again trust
me
i think you a little bit
not not like a ton
no
i see it a tiny bit but because you guys
are gingers
wow
it's just the beard that's ginger though
the hair isn't so the hair's strawberry
blonde
what you are hey it's the beard the
beard's definitely ginger
oh it's your hair it's kind of rare it's
quite rather that's just the lighting
of christ actually yeah does the ginger
was there anything else that ruffled
your feathers on the podcast
um
i don't think so
it was a good watch though yeah yeah
yeah
well i appreciate you coming on
it's been fun yeah yeah yeah did you
come on again 100 you're gonna come on
thursday one thursday what's the topic i
don't haven't thought of it yet
i usually think of them the day before i
mean yeah thursday night i'll be
[Music]
you could bring her oh my god can i
grill you guys live
she won't want that
can i get my actual personal talking to
you girl you're talking to oh my gosh i
can like
i'll make it super fun it'll be like a
fun date okay like tell her tell her
you're going on a date okay
don't tell her where i told her i'm here
tonight i don't know but like tell her
bring her here and sit her there and
i'll just ask you guys like really
uncomfortable questions but it'll make
really good content
i'd have to talk to him about it but
it's okay
um okay in a few weeks
okay guys um do not forget to subscribe
to the channel go follow his instagram
it is in the description you can say
your instagram or any other sam
underscore james97
okay guys um don't forget to subscribe
to the channel thank you for the super
chat